I know one thing
never wake up
this family
[Music]
is our Fortress
once I saw the film it was like I
couldn't speak because it's like an
experience I know you've talked about
how sometimes when you see something for
the first time like you get quiet what
was the reaction
um what sort of you and how did it
compare to the first one I don't
remember I I don't I don't remember how
what my reaction was in the first one
but I'm pretty sure they might have been
the same
um I'd start talking gibberish I cry I
shut down and then
um and then I process and through the
trans course of of the tour which we
find ourselves 13 years later again
um you know emotional beats will come
out the more I watch it so I'm looking
forward to watching it again it was
special it was an experience that I that
I just felt through all my senses I'm
extremely proud of gem and of the team
I'm just so proud of everybody and I
feel so lucky to be to be a part of a
story that that is um is very compelling
it's interesting because I was thinking
about the evolution of both of your
characters and for you Sam I noticed his
movements this time around like he's
more like I think you described Like a
Warrior this time around last time there
was a naivete to when he became big and
blue and this time your body language
everything changed can you talk about
how you prepared differently or how you
keyed into him in a different way well
he's been living with the navi for 10
years so he's assimilating in a certain
way he's losing his human traits in some
respect and becoming more Primal
um but I think you know that's what we
we wanted we didn't want to replicate
the first movie you want this whole Saga
to be this progression of these
characters and Jake and the Terry's love
story is at the center now they have the
natural progression of that which is the
family but the the characters are going
to evolve and keep evolving that's one
of the exciting things about doing these
movies is that
we're not just doing carbon copy
characters the cut and paste where Jim
wants us to kind of you know as always
been saying work backwards you know we
know where it's going so we work
backwards to kind of fill in the gaps
and then we start filming more yeah
where is each of your Pandora in life
where's the place on Earth that you find
magical either worldly
my children and my husband too he gets
to come too he's quite he's quite lovely
but it's um I think it's in bed when my
whole family is just sleeping you get a
big jungle bed I know it's a big button
we don't even fit it's five of them like
man-eating plants in there I know but
like here to hear everybody's breathing
uh is it to me is like scuba yeah
yeah
man
no but that's that's my Haven that's my
safe place what about you now you have
to say he's asleep no everyone knows
it's going to be my kids yeah my wife
everyone knows that oh yeah and I heard
you that you have dad jokes Trinity says
that you have dad jokes oh I gotta hear
those that's what I am of any joke is a
bad joke because I'm a dad
[Music]
but I get I guess he gets to he gets to
make those jokes around the kids
so little anymore
cast
uh Sally children have grown bigger I'm
actually the smallest now they've all
grown oh my gosh really yeah way bigger
than me yeah wow it's kind of amazing
yeah I know you're a trickier than happy
real quick
um what kind of like I really felt and
you've talked about the family the
connection was so deep in this one I
really felt are you two having
conversations
sort of to support each other on set
going like oh that was a tough day or
that was like you two seem so bonded you
you do look the characters are fire
first we just happen to be in water you
know there's an elemental nature to this
and I think when you approach it with
that kind of baseness
and then you stop you have to have a bit
of fun and relax and calm and as of
Avatar family we have that we have that
kind of familiarity and Trust in each
other to then be operatic in what these
scenes demand and be challenging and and
Primal and and and take it to that you
know up the ante a bit on what these
level what these scenes can can do
absolutely but you have to have that
balance yeah yeah and but also like I'm
going to talk about you like you're not
here like Sam is not an entitled person
he doesn't get in his own way he's like
a true artist he allows the process to
to take over and um he just makes it
feel so safe for everybody there's no
ego uh when you work with Sam so he is
he's a giver and not a taker so that
compels you to always have his back
because he has yours
um there and and I think that we bonded
because we were like these kids getting
this unimaginable opportunity back in
2006 when he chose us he chose us out of
like thousands of people that that they
had sent tapes of and and he felt that
you know Sam was his Jake and then I was
his natiri there was no chance in hell
that we were going to take that for
granted
um I do look up to say I'm like there's
just there's level of humility to his
character as an artist as a person too
and um that every time I feel a little
wobbly that's kind of like reassuring so
getting to go back to that and then
would you have someone like Jim that is
setting such a powerful tone of respect
and camaraderie and collaboration but
also of Excellence that um it just
trickles down to each and every one of
us too
the way of water connects all things
before your birth
and after your death you
for he has talked a little bit about how
he felt like you had such an affinity to
sort of being underwater he felt like it
was like a creative sandbox for you it
was actually yeah that's a really good
way of putting it I I felt so kind of I
felt so comfortable in the water I mean
I'm just I'm unafraid of physical
challenge
um but certainly this one I love the
water I love to swim I'm in and on the
water a lot do cold water swimming so I
know what my body is capable of
um but actually I have to say that the
process of working under the water was
so specific it was a very finely tuned
experience you know with Titanic we dump
however many tons of water into a
flooding dining room and there's only so
much that you can possibly know about
how that water is going to behave around
us as actors around the crew around the
set you know pieces of chair and dining
tables sliding across the room so there
was always the element of the unknown
that was really nerve-wracking for
everybody but with Avatar everyone knew
exactly what to expect there was a whole
system in terms of everyone taking in
their final Peak inhalation which is the
Breath You Take before you go under
everyone knowing how many seconds they
had to get down there and get in
position every camera operator had two
safety divers every actor had two safety
divers on them so it was an amazing
system so we all felt just completely
free to explore the scenes wow so the
when the acting is supported to such an
extent it's a really magnificent thing I
have to say and it was very special it
was a really unique special experience I
loved it when you saw your character for
the first time I don't know what and
what part of the process that happened
but how much did it inform you as an
actress well so I I saw a lot of
Graphics a lot of just visual material
literally like images on pieces of paper
um mock-ups that the designers and the
costume designer had worked on together
of what I would look like and it was
just exciting and tremendous I mean I
think the power of her and that's
something I really appreciate about
Jim's writing is that he really
celebrates the power of women the power
of mothers and in particular that theme
of mother I felt so strongly in the
script and so when I saw my character I
just felt excited you know and Jim would
describe how how her arms were a little
bit thicker around here so she could
swim faster the girth of the tail is
wider so they can get through the water
with with greater speed
um and I just appreciated all those
little attentions that were paid to
detail and
um I couldn't wait I just couldn't wait
for all of it and it certainly did I
think impact on the stature how I held
myself because I could see his intention
for her how she what her sort of Aura
was and so I definitely was able to take
a little bit of that from the visuals
that I was shown and hopefully work it
into the character it's interesting
because that was my next question she
had a very specific way of moving I
don't even know if I would call it
walking but moving
um how did you come up with that well
there was a movement coach who worked
with everybody and that just helped me I
think to feel confident with the with
the movement because you sort of you you
almost you hold the head back and
shoulders shoulders are back
um but hips are forward so they're sort
of lead with uh with the kind of with
the with the stomach and and the pelvis
and it's a really interesting way of
moving but actually Zoe also helped me
too
um because of course she is so she's so
natively she's so that word and it was
wonderful her sharing with me and
learning from her and she was so much a
part of the voices and the creation of
the movement in the early days of the
first film and so to have her experience
and and and to listen and learn from her
was really special so this year is the
25th anniversary of Titanic when you
look back and now that you've worked
with Jim again the film is Real This
film is releasing on the 25th
anniversary how has he evolved as a
filmmaker and when you look back on that
experience
how do you see it now like what do you
what do you what do you feel now when
you when you look back I think Jim you
know Jim is a filmmaker I think he's
evolved as a filmmaker because he's so
much evolved as a person you know I
think I've hopefully evolved as an actor
because I've also evolved as a person
and the things that we experience in our
lives but also through the work that we
do and the directors and the actors that
we work with they change who we are and
what we can bring into the room and I
just I look back on the experience of
Titanic and you know I just I of course
remember how hard it was how how much we
all stuck together but also I really
treasure the friendships that we made
and the cast and the crew you know those
are the things that when you can walk
away from an experience and look back
and remember the really really great
parts and that for me is what I remember
more than anything is that sense of
camaraderie and everyone looking out for
each other
um but my God we were in it all together
I mean Jim and I you know we've laughed
about things like oh my god do you
remember how those Hydraulics would
break and it would be this tried and
supposedly tried and tested systems and
every now I you know something would
break or change and we'd have to wait
three hours while it was getting fixed
and you know it was yeah I look back at
the kind of haphazard nature of which so
many of those things were thrown
together and my goodness it's a miracle
it all it all came together in the end
but luckily it did you broke a record
which everybody's going to be talking
about for holding your breath underwater
congratulations seven minutes 20 seconds
I think seven minutes fourteen I was
giving you a few extra that's okay what
goes through your mind like minute six
is it does you get it I wasn't even
aware and actually when I so the
previous the previous uh stay maybe two
days previously I had done a breath hold
that was six minutes 14 and I was
incredibly proud of myself and so on
that breath hold I was really determined
that day I tried to just you know get my
eating right get my my sort of
temperament right because you do have to
calm your whole nervous system down and
actually how you live you start to live
in certain ways that you know we're
going to maximize your physical and
physical ability and your lung capacity
to be able to do it so that day I was
just so quietly determined and I said to
my husband who was there I said oh
please don't come today because I know
that Kirk's going to get me to do
another breath hold and I just really
don't want to feel the pressure of you
being there and he was like okay but he
snuck in and so I actually have video
footage of me coming up which he was
sneakily taking on his phone
so I come up and I go am I dead am I
dead have I died am I dead am I dead and
I say how long was that straight away
I'm like how long was that I wanted to
know right away and Kirk said how long
do you think it was and I said I don't
know it could have been 6 10 it could
have been 7 10 I have absolutely no idea
and when he told me it was 7 14 I just I
mean I just scream I just couldn't
believe it and I'm like someone radio
Jim and let them know I just smashed my
own record so I was yeah very proud of
myself but I had no idea what was going
on at minute six all I was thinking was
don't take a breath don't take a breath
just keep going keep going
um yeah very proud of myself
so what does her heartbeat sound like
[Music]
a little bit of your reaction but I'm
really curious to know because it seems
like both you and Zoe are having such a
deep visceral experience with watching
it can you sort of
break down how you felt watching it and
compare it to when you saw the first
film I love the first film it has an
amazing story and it introduces us to
natiri and her world and it's so
powerful and so moving and romantic this
to me was not a movie it was an
experience and from the moment it starts
I felt like even though I play a member
of the family I felt like a member of
the family and I was completely
committed to whatever was going on with
us it was just a seamless transition to
being in Pandora and at every level
technologically and emotionally the
story was
it has you it just it's like a big
animal that grabs you and just holds you
for three hours and um and then uh lets
you go and it I'm still assimilating The
Experience because I'd never you know I
had hoped that Carrie would work but it
was a big risk that Jim took and really
that I took and I was so
delighted and relieved to see that that
Carrie is the special character we
wanted to create well that's what I
wanted to talk to you about because the
last time we spoke about this I hadn't
seen the film and you talked about Kerry
being very special
she is so unique
her movements she's awkward in her
movements I want to know how you as an
actress on set like how you sort of got
into her body and and and made her and I
think you that was sort of a suggestion
of yours maybe to make her feel a little
more awkward and not so perfect yes when
I saw the sketches of Carrie she had a
little band on her head and she's very
naterially like very composed and pretty
and I said to Jim you know
I don't remember feeling like that I I
would never have dreamed of being as
pretty as my mother or as capable you
know I took a long time to sort of cook
so that period of time for me is very
very Vivid and I just felt like for a
lot of women a lot of girls that's not a
happy perfectly happy time of course the
Great Moments of great happiness and fun
but there are also moments where you're
you just want to disappear and you just
feel things are so unjust and so I
wanted that to be part of her story uh I
thought how can it not be because of
what happens to the family she's she's
pulled from this this absolute
Wonderland this this golden childhood
into into this new world and um and
loses her best friend and you know so I
just felt like it was a complicated time
for all of them but especially for
someone who's an adolescent how did you
develop develop those movements of her
but like was that something that just
sort of came did you work on that a lot
well I did because luckily the film kept
being put the shooting kept being
postponed so I I realized early on that
I didn't want to play a teenager I
wanted to become a teenager and very
specifically the Kiri teenager so I
would get on the set every day and I'd
worked on this before I we started
shooting just
trying to be get back to the body I felt
I was in when I was 14. and I'd go and
stand on off in the corner and I would
just try to let all of Sigourney go and
just be really who is Susie you know and
she didn't even like her name so um uh
you know and just drop everything away
and actually what amazes me like
um when I said to Sam at one point I
said you you deserve an acting award for
being able to do scenes with me and
believe that I'm 14. he said it just
dropped away from you every time we were
doing a scene and and I was so amazed by
that and and frankly so heartened by
that you've talked about your
relationship with Jim that you have a
very playful relationship I'm wondering
when you were in the tank and he's able
to give you notes and sort of like talk
over a loudspeaker or however that you
can hear him what are sort of like the
funny notes or fun conversations not
conversations you can't speak back but
what are sort of the funny some funny
dialogue he was giving you as you were
filming those scenes was it as playful
as I'm imagining it was I think it yes I
mean yes he's always playful
um I think there was so much going on
for him and he would say you know once
we before we shoot it soon try to come
up above there was like this much
plastic white bowls over the whole
surface of the tank
excuse me um
so that to keep out the reflections so
when you when they said cut and you had
to wait for your safety divers who would
swoop in and kind of lift you back up to
the surface because I was wearing
weights and stuff I wouldn't have made
it without them
you had to hold your breath long enough
to pass that three inches of of uh
little balls because and Jim would
always say try not to swallow a ball as
you come up you know things like that
[Music]
well why are you like you I'm supposed
to fight
[Music]
this is an extraordinary role you were
unbelievable in this role you mean you
didn't believe me we talked the last
time no I believed you but seeing is
believing right
um what I found really interesting and a
lot of people you have such a fandom
people love you and love this character
so excited but the big question was like
how does he come back how did you find
out how this was going to be possible I
know that you've worked with James over
the years you've been collaborators but
when did you first find out well I knew
I would be back how I would be back I
didn't know but you know as when people
say but how could he come back didn't
you die you know nobody says it better
than than Jim Cameron he'd kind of look
and say it's called science fiction duh
you know I hope you're not saying that
to me right now no okay I'm just the
messenger but anyway I uh it was when I
I look I suspected all along that it it
had something to do with my DNA you know
knowing our D.A the way I do I knew that
you know of course they'd Bank my DNA
look courage represents it's a
calculation it's a cold equation to them
that that that I'm an investment to them
and it costs them zero to bank the DNA
and if if they they do they run the
numbers and say is it worth it bringing
this guy back you know he did a pretty
good job until uh till uh things went
South on them but uh that's really not
entirely his fault although some of it's
his fault anyway yeah let's bring the
son of a gun back and we'll send them up
there again and and you know to see if
we can get this thing solved you just
played a whole new character I know
that's an RDA some some Wonton ideas
some some business dude right there and
I think that that I think it was as
simple as that yeah the the decision so
you get the big and blue treatment in
this film and I was watching your
character wondering what is courage
feeling because he always wants to be
bigger than he is right and now he
physically is so what does that do for
you as an actor when all of a sudden
you're playing this character like how
did it inform how he moved how he talked
in this film versus the last one yeah
it's an interesting thing you say he
always wants to be bigger I'm not I'd
have to exam I'm going to accept it okay
okay so maybe it's true uh he wants to
be as big as he possibly can he takes up
a lot of space
cord she tends to be he tends to
dominate the room even if he is not
saying anything just his presence you
know he's got he's he's a true leader in
that way and that's the strength and I
think it's one of the things that people
uh kind of respond to in him and of
course when it becomes an avatar he's
learned some lessons he's not a stupid
man by any means and uh if he uh by
being one way it ended up with two
arrows in his chest maybe it's time to
make an adjustment in how he is dealing
with the environment and with the
denizens of that environment and I think
he becomes uh you know pretty Adept at
doing that he we see him starting on the
journey and going a long way in Avatar
way of water he's adapting to the uh to
to Pandora rather than trying to make
Pandora adapt to him speaking of
adapting in the last one you're human in
this one you're doing a lot of mocap
compare for me as an actor being in the
mocap working outfit opposite humans
versus is being a human working opposite
mocap how do you compare that
um do I just blow your mind yeah yeah
I'm trying to yeah yeah uh look
performance capture is uh it's
challenging weather and uh working and I
will tell you that working in
performance capture with working with
live action human it's it's difficult
because of scale
because you're dealing because you know
understand that I'm if I'm acting in a
scene say with Edie falca who plays
General Ardmore and this she's a human
in this and and I'm an avatar well if
I'm if Edie and I are standing next to
each other acting and I'm supposed to be
looking at her I really have to look
down at her kneecap in order to make eye
contact with her you know what I mean
yeah yeah that makes sense right it's
like because the scale is because I'm
actually you know 14 or 12 feet tall and
so that I know this is kind of a little
wacky no I talk about it's hard it's
hard to talk about and when we're when
we're on this when we're on set and and
Jim is is kind of figuring it out you
know too it can get a little like uh so
where do you want me to look uh uh uh
okay so that's challenging that's just
flat out technically challenging and be
difficult to do but that's the
circumstances we work under and and you
have no alternative but to make it into
a positive right you know what I mean
and it becomes such you know it's all a
question of approach yeah I know I heard
you say something about like you turn
challenges into like obstacles into like
a resource to like if you can I mean I
think that's a good I think you know
makes sense to do that yeah
um really specific
ity
the way you hold the coffee cup or
whatever you have I remembered the first
film
was that a choice as an actor were you
like I want to have that cup and there's
something about the way he holds it it's
very like and you talked about right
angles the last time we talked yeah
exactly was that a choice that you made
or was that always I think it's an
organic choice I mean I would probably
look at the Monitor and see if I liked
the way I was you know leaning there
possibly or it just felt right or Jim
said I like that that's good lift it a
little higher or whatever you know it
can be any number of things but I know
the coffee cup was was important I
wasn't initially pleased with The Coffee
Cup itself I had wanted something uh uh
different I wanted something metallic
and I wanted steam coming off it and uh
uh and and you know
and and that didn't happen it's like
well I remember saying we're in New
Zealand are there no coffee cups in New
Zealand to our wonderful prop man you
know you know I don't want to diss
anybody but it worked out good
apparently the coffee cup was memorable
enough so I'm glad I brought it out
I saw
that Edie had a coffee cup in this one
General Ardmore is having a cup of
coffee
how about that how about that I just I
talked about the fandom a little bit
earlier on but have you experienced that
do you you know do people come up to you
and talk to you about what quartz
because people love him he's a villain
you know occasionally I do I mean you
know I could I could you get people from
all kinds I get them from Tombstone a
lot I love Tombstone when I get it from
don't breathe weird you know
my fan base is they're a strange group
but very very good do you know when they
walk up which film they're going to
excite you you know what that's a great
question sometimes I do you know you
kind of and sometimes they'll surprise
you
I need you
with me and I need you to be strong
strong heart
back when you did the first Avatar film
in 2009
we all connected with it obviously the
highest grossing film of all time but
there was a very deep connection people
had to it something you called the
tertiary level yeah okay so you've done
your research that's great yeah what did
you experience on a churchilly tertiary
level that made you want to continue
this story and dedicate 10 years of your
life to well I felt that the unequivocal
success of the movie was was some kind
of subconscious connection that people
were making around the world and it
actually gave me hope you know it was a
message that that was you know
thematically it was it was about the
environment about nature about our
connection to Nature that we all feel
even though we live in this kind of
state of nature deficit disorder which
we all do and most of us do unless
you're still you know on a farm or you
get to be a forest ranger or something
like that you know but I thought that
okay so we have evidence now from the
success of this film that people want to
connect they feel some kind of
subconscious connection to these ideas
and these images all right now how do we
do that again and how do we build on
that and we literally wrote a whole
script that I wasn't happy with I didn't
think it did it and we chucked it out it
was about a Year's work we chucked it
out and started over uh because I wanted
that I wanted that subconscious
connection that's almost dreamlike right
I wanted to awaken that you know kind of
sense memory of maybe in this film of
being in water or underwater or that
yearning that we have to see a primeval
world like that because you know there
was a time when human beings lived in a
primeval world and and they were
relatively happy for hundreds of
thousands of years and then they
invented our modern civilization and
things kind of went a little bit
pear-shaped right so it's meant to be
kind of a reminder of the stuff that's
deep deeply coded inside us
um and I'd like to hope that we
accomplish that again in a different way
so it's new it's fresh it's a it's a new
story new challenges all that sort of
thing I feel like in a sense you're a
met kaina yourself okay well I do I do
like the water I do like being
underwater sure so so there's a
reverence right there's a reverence for
the ocean there's a reverence for what
that not be called the Great balance for
me it's just the awe and wonder of
what's really there what what I call it
Nature's imagination wow so speaking of
that technology in that modern world
that you talked about
um
I think when people talk about your
films they always say James Cameron
waited for the technology to catch up to
his vision that's something we hear over
and over and over again yeah but for you
what was something that you weren't able
to do in 2009 because it the technology
didn't exist for you who hadn't created
it yet they gave you particular joy to
be able to bring to this film yeah the
difference for the new film was that
previously I was just waiting for the
rising tide to lift All Ships together
so that then we could come in and we
could build on top of it to create what
we needed for the first Avatar and it
was all very prototypical and so on uh
like the whole movie was a prototype
but we learned from that and then when
we set down the path of doing these
these new sequels we actually you know
in a very focused way built the new
tools that we needed we didn't wait we
didn't wait for the industry at large to
do it for us we we knew what we needed
and we we went after it and and a big
Focus was how do we create literally a
perfect translation of what the actors
are doing into their characters their
characters aren't human their bodies are
different their faces are different how
do we make sure that what the actor does
um gets there 100 with no loss
whatsoever and then a lot of money and a
lot of time went into that and I think
we've accomplished that because when you
see
whether it's Sam Zoe Sigourney
Kate Winslet you you feel them even when
they're not talking you feel what
they're what they're feeling what
they're thinking it's all there 100 and
so we're very happy with that and and
now that's the base from which we can
move forward through these other films
if we get to make the other films
obviously it's interesting because you
do experience it
on that level people talk about the
first avatar how it was groundbreaking
they never seen anything like it I felt
that watching this again I felt like I
had seen something I'd never seen before
because that was our goal because you
are always thinking forward is there a
piece of technology that you're now
working on for the future whether it be
a future Avatar film or something you
hope exists in the future that maybe
whether it be Avatar another film that
you I don't think there's anything that
we need that we don't have now we gave
ourselves all the hard problems in this
movie Water being the hardest problem
but water fire everything the the
emotional stuff so we gave ourselves all
the hard problems on purpose so that we
now don't have so now the Cadence of the
films can be shorter like we plan to
drop the next one in two years and then
after that another couple years two or
three years you see what I mean so we
don't have to create it all from from
scratch uh anymore where my focus is to
promote better exhibition right so the
3D is great but not all 3D theaters are
bright enough for for my standard you
know you got to see it in A nice bright
theater but they're not all not all
bright enough and uh you know some
people don't like 3D because the
theatrical technology has lagged behind
what we what we can do you know you saw
it in its most pristine form
um so yeah my emphasis is on on getting
kind of the infrastructure out there up
to the level that it can be where do you
see 13 years since the last film if you
jump forward 13 years from now how do
you think we're going to be experiencing
movies I think it'll be fairly similar
to what it is right now I mean there's
something you know uh
my biggest challenges on this film are
not technological they were they were
dramatic they were narrative you know
what are we trying to say what's the
story that we're trying to tell because
people people are mostly interested in
story then when they go to see a movie
they don't want to know like what kind
of camera was used really you know they
just want like do I care about this
character is it is it funny is it
dramatic does it make me cry does it
make me feel something right so that
that storytelling challenge will always
be there yeah and if the medium changes
it doesn't really matter you know the
big question right now is that to be or
not to be questioned does the theatrical
experience mean enough to human
civilization to keep it alive in a in a
time of of Rapid access to content you
know it's like a fire hose coming at you
right now as all these different
streamers are spending so much money to
create so much interesting content with
good actors and good writing and all
that but can that sustain itself I think
we're seeing the signs that it can't not
at the level that is is right now and we
see people coming back to the theater
because they want that you know whether
it's the communal experience I think of
it more as the experience where you make
it deal with yourself to not pick up the
remote for three hours that's really
what it is it's I'm just going to focus
on that and let it let it you know bathe
me in this story and in these people you
know and you don't do that at all you
know it's just a fundamentally different
experience deposit you go make a phone
call or order a pizza or text somebody
or you know it's a divided attention or
you you know you watch it in bits I just
asked Kate 25 years since Titanic to
reflect on you as a filmmaker how you've
evolved
when you look back on that experience
now having so much distance from it are
you able to watch it as a how do you see
it looking back and what is it about you
because both films you're an epic
filmmaker what quality do you think you
have that allows you to become to be an
epic filmmaker
well look I'm an artist right so I I
think in kind of these moving paintings
if you will you know I love production
value I love spectacle physical
spectacle whether it's done virtually or
whether it's done with with physical
sets
but I think that that's that's necessary
but not sufficient right I think what
you also need is a a deep concern for
the characters in the writing stage
you've got to love your characters and
and then you've got to find the right
actors to play those characters and
you've got to love your actors and
you've got to care about them you know
and work with them and support them to
do their their very best work I had a
great working relationship with Kate and
Leonardo on on Titanic
I think you know for these these young
actors where they were they were
established they had done they had done
some great work but they had a lot of
challenges on that film and I'm I'm
proud of what we created together you
know I'm proud of Kate having gone on to
the Stellar career that she's had it was
great for us to reunite and celebrate
each other you know that we're now you
know kind of 25 years down the line
we've we've made our bones in the in the
business you know and we can relax and
have have fun and it was a challenging
role for her physically right because of
the water and all that she had but she
loved that you know because she's the
kind of actor that just loves a physical
challenge or anything to do with dialect
or language I mean it basically was
everything for her you know because she
loves the sound of of of dialect and the
sound of language she had to learn some
not not be uh because she does a couple
scenes in Nabi there's no reason for
that right because the whole the
Conceited the whole movie is that
everybody's speaking Navi but we're
hearing it in English like a World War a
bunch of World War II Germans you know
then I'll speak with English accents for
some reason you know that's the conceit
of the film but when she does her her
kind of shamanistic practice we went to
Navi well maybe it's an archaic form of
Navi that's part of their their ceremony
or something like that you know anyway
it was great working with her again
treat them as our brothers and sisters
we're like
literally when we watched it for the
first time yesterday it didn't hit until
like like the the 20th Century Fox
started and I was just like oh this is
happening holy crap you know when the
20th century came on and they went
it just yeah chills adrenaline through
the veins so when you see yourselves big
in blue or in whatever iteration that
you are do you see yourselves or do you
see the character or do you see both
like is it weird to see yourself in it
both I'd say both I see more myself
because I just I also judge my own
performance you know as an actor but I
also I also see the character in it um
but yeah both
when watching the stuff that I'd done I
also tend to sometimes
you know you're your own worst critic
often and
um but seeing this I think in this movie
there's just so much to take in and I'm
trying to take all of it in and to I
just
um
yeah I take just have so much love in my
heart whenever I look at my little took
and she does have my separated teeth of
like buck teeth from when I was eight
years old and uh my peanut body from
then so it's it's I love her did you get
braces no Invisalign Invisalign nice I
noticed your laugh in the movie like
your laugh just was like so you were
like the lightness in a sense thank you
so much did you notice did you were you
aware like was Jim giving you notes or
was that a natural thing that you know
that you were just impromptu laughing I
guess it's just kind of took in her
personality and
um she's kind of always trying to find
the positivity and the beauty of what's
happening in this film and what's
happening to the sullies and everything
but
um I think Jim there's this scene when
they arrive at the metcalina village and
of course it goes from two really
missing home to also kind of exploring
this new home that they have and jump
jumping up and down and going
and I remember that
um day that when I was just jumping up
and down Jim and I were trying to figure
out what sound took might do and
um we ended up then Jim said wondered to
himself what would a Pandora and
Kangaroo sound like and then we just
kind of like played around with what
took thought of Pandora and Kangaroo
sound like and I guess Pandora kangaroos
to took sound like
um but oh my gosh it's just at Jim's I'm
such an amazing director and
um really through that we got to
discover Tucson or monologue and stuff
like that so and for you I mean spiders
motions are insane like I was like how
is a human doing that because sometimes
when you see the Avatar bodies you
understand how they can move like that
but can you talk a little bit about how
you prepared as an actor to be so
immersive I mean that was incredible I
did a lot of training
um I did same training as them uh with
like parkour knife training movement
training bone arrow training but also I
worked with the stunt guys and I got my
own trainer
um nice and Josh Maria who I worked with
for four years still worked with to this
day actually and he helped me go from
like a pudgy 12 year old to someone who
looked like they could you know actually
live in the jungle um
swole yeah
um and yeah no it was
uh it was just like a lot of training
for especially specific shots where I'm
like running and doing parkour to look
like I've been doing it my whole life
and yeah a lot of choreography I heard
something I think you said before that
Sam tells dad joke jokes and it's so
funny because when I think of Sam I
think of Sam kind of like from the
Avatar one and it's so funny that you
see him like oh he's like a dad so what
were his dad jokes that you were talking
about well it's funny that you say that
because also me having watched Avatar so
many times before I met Sam I expected
to be meeting of Jake like person and uh
like that he'd be very serious and
heroic but actually Sam is very just
nurturing and fun and tells good dad
jokes he does so they're good jokes yeah
sometimes dad jokes are bad jokes right
I mean if Dad jokes are bad that's kind
of why they're good right yeah that's a
good point yeah but his his dry delivery
really brings it home especially when he
says what the hot dog
he said that yeah okay
um I know before you started filming
James took you both or took a lot of the
cast to Hawaii to sort of do like feel
the sand in your feet can you kind of
walk me through how does that feel when
like James is like your ultimate tour
guide in Hawaii telling you just like
smell the smells and feel the feels like
what is that what does that feel like it
was cool because I think I just booked
the role like a week prior and then it
was like you're flying out to Hawaii I
was like okay so me and my mom went to
Hawaii and I went to all right we went
to like the ocean the first official day
and uh some of the casts scuba dived and
I didn't have my scuba license so I just
like snorkeled and I spent like four
hours straight in the ocean and then
when I went back up on the on like the
little uh not ship a boat I immediately
got seasick and threw up no way yeah I
felt really sick and then and I was like
hang up the side of the boat and Jim
came up to me swimming he was like hey
buddy how was your first day at uh at
Navi summer camp and I was like it's
great yeah like so yeah hope he wasn't
swimming in your throw up no they no I
threw up and they all came to watch the
fish feed off of it no yeah it's true
it's like I'm getting such a visual now
oh my God that's kind of a that's it's
gross but kind of cool it's kind
so I never like to ask this question
because I know actors don't necessarily
give actors advice but I heard Kate say
she actually liked giving the younger
cast advice so was that something that
happened and
there was also a swear jar so on the two
ends of the spectrum who was giving the
advice who was doing the swearing I feel
like
Sam gave me plenty of advice but also
did plenty of swearing you know yeah
um as the founders of the swear jar we
can definitely say Sam was a primary
contributor yes
um but also Sam did he was really good
at giving advice and was always there
for me
um yeah and he was very yeah into the
scene and would help me get into the
scene emotionally and stuff yeah so we
really got to learn from the adult cast
and also supportive and just fun kind
and
definitely we got to get lots of advice
I remember one day when I was kind of
nervous about this one scene and Sid
came up to me and just kind of made me
feel really confident and prepared for
it and
um it's just to watch them do their
stuff and kind of get to learn from them
that way too yeah I just watched watched
them perform in itself is an honor
where's your Pandora where on this Earth
is your personal Haven your personal
Pandora well first if Pandora were a
real place it would be top of my bucket
list yeah but I guess we get to go there
in the theater you know yeah there's a
place in in there's like a glacier Lake
in the south island of New Zealand which
is beautiful but also my home of the
mountains of Appalachia is also really
beautiful so
um yeah I think the mountains of
Appalachia I'd say that that's my home
there's yeah there's still a lot of
beautiful places that I'd love to see
one day and explore and a lot of
Pandora's I guess I'd love to explore
but I guess right now just wherever my
family and my friends and people I love
are that's my Pandora we cannot let you
bring your War here outcast
that's all they see
uh it's is it true that you all went to
Hawaii sort of for like a pre-production
trip to sort of get your senses because
you're going to be in a tank and you're
going to be shooting where you don't
sort of have all the elements what is
that trip like because like summer camp
is Jim giving you like oh you know like
okay look at the tree look feel the sand
how does that go yes well I think you
put it perfectly it was like a
pre-production training situation
especially because we were doing some so
much training in the volume and in this
gray space and then we go to Hawaii and
for me personally at that time I've
never been out of the states so I've
barely been on the west coast being from
New York so being able to go to Hawaii
which feels like its own place outside
of anywhere like just its own Island
which it literally you know is and
because of that we were able to immerse
ourselves even like feeling Jim would be
like feel the sand feel the creatures
around you the reefs being able to scuba
dive and go deep into the water all of
that really helped you know you never
forget those Moon elements even as just
a regular person not doing acting in a
volume but to be able to have that and
then go into the volume just expanded
the whole acting process I think James
must be the ultimate cam counselor in a
sense
he's like the ultimate tour guide
um I was wondering for you guys when you
see yourselves
given the big and blue treatment
do you see yourselves or do you see a
different character like when you watch
yourselves and saw yourselves for the
first time is it like oh that's me or do
you feel like you're watching something
outside yourself
we've talked about this one haven't we
because I I personally as an actor love
like transcending quality of acting and
if you go into a cinema and don't have
to look at yourself then that's
extremely forgiving and kind of
everything why
I like to do it to experience something
outside of yourself yeah well it's the
same with any character I play if I
don't see myself I did a good job so I
see Bailey like that those are my
dimples those are my teeth my my
cheekbones added to the shape of cedaya
so it is my body the same way it is when
I do live action but if we did our jobs
as actors which I really feel we did we
shouldn't feel ourselves and if you
can continue going this is
such a good role and you just had to be
self-deprecating he does a great job
that's that's how you know he did a
great job because he's being
self-deprecating and that's a fact oh
that's horrible then so maybe it's
self-deprecation is just like a
reevaluation for me to get a compliment
yeah
it works this is getting deep
I didn't even mean to use a pun
it just ultimately happened so is there
anything and maybe you do experience as
me is there anything a mannerism of
something you didn't realize that you
had until you saw yourself in this sort
of way
I didn't realize how much my smile
impacted people
because my whole life like people would
always say like oh my gosh your smile
you know your brightness and all of that
and seeing today as smile and I think
it's just because
that's everything that she is in this
movie like her overall kindness and I
would all when people ask me to describe
her I say kind but I did not realize how
like infectious my own kindness is
Bailey and my own smile is on others
until it transformed into performance
capture this was this this one scene in
the film where you do like a sad Smile
as well there's variations there's
variations on the smile it's a dynamics
that was actually really sad like yeah
but Jim cares so much about those
details and he would go into every scene
explaining it in Great depth and because
of that we get those variations of what
a person is and I think that's one of
the beautiful parts of this movie is how
specific every character is very much so
and I love that you're self-deprecating
and you reflected the question back to
her instead of answering about your own
mannerisms there you go yeah
so you're used to being in the water but
there are moments where you're supposed
to be a couple of your characters are
sort of like needing a breath and you
sort of do that gesture of like when we
all know we're underwater and we're
running out of breath how do you
actually do that on the day so that
we're not seeing bubbles like how are
you acting that out as an actor you've
literally just reminded me about a very
strict note from Jim and the diving team
which I completely forgot about which is
yeah if we
did allow bubbles to leave it would go
in front of the camera and we'd
completely mess up their shot
um so it's something that free divers
used to communicate underwater yeah it
is it's something we learned in training
and we you just
and that's what you do but also like
because I know the scenes you're
referring to
um and I've what I love about those
scenes and why the actors that do
without giving too much away the actors
that have to act the running out of
breath it's such a natural instinct that
actually that's why I feel like it's so
evocative I've definitely done that in
scenes where I wasn't meant to be doing
that so well the also the number one
fear in humans or like one of our top 10
fears is drowning so naturally even when
we're going into training we have to
learn to not be afraid of drowning
should we get consensus on that are we
all afraid to drown yeah oh my god I've
almost I've almost drowned so many times
that I'm grateful for Avatar training
now you know you'll be fine yeah it's
the moment I I know that there was when
you were in the um in the tank I keep
calling it The Tank but
um when Jim was able to talk with you
what was sort of like the funniest note
or like something that he shouted out
that you're like this is I'm so in an
Avatar film right now with James it's
really too much to remember
I have one go for it yeah yeah um so we
have to wear goggles and well you can't
Jamie was the only actor that did scenes
without goggles and a nose clip and I
just I was like this person is
superhuman because we're like diving
deep and having to equalize so he would
just go quickly equalize with his nose
right and then go down yeah
no but that's not true because Jim was
very grateful for that because then they
didn't have to remove the nose clip and
goggles while filming while they were
doing the performance capture so
um I would say the weirdest thing was
Jim asked me he's like so can you do
without the goggles and nose clip and
I'm just like where when does this
happen where like he we are wearing all
these extra things that no one will ever
see what was the moment that both of you
were just like
like was it watching the film for the
first time or you're like wow I'm
actually in an avatar of movie like this
is insane
yeah because this is only obviously from
the actors experience this has nothing
to do with the audience they're going to
go through but um we've had so much time
in between filming it and actually
seeing the film that actually all of my
um in an introspection over like the
film process has already sort of
happened before we saw the film and
there was an amazing like distance away
from the process uh away from being an
actor in the film when when watching it
I'd say that final day of finally
rapping on set
yeah because there's been such a
formative and it's always weirdly into
your environment because we only had
like yes five of us to rely on is
growing up with each other in L.A an
alien world to a lot of us and um no
offense and um
um and then no no no because I
we were none of us were front most of us
were not from La so we were like this is
like a whole new place
um but I think for me it was watching
the film yesterday and seeing
anytime I see my credit on a film it it
like makes me ball because you know you
I worked very hard to get where I am now
and the nose like I don't think people
understand the amount of no it's not
getting even a call back so to be able
to see seraya Bailey bass in the credits
I hope that never gets old and I don't
think it ever will if you want to live
here
you have to ride
let's do it
now how you guys you and your work
spouse James managed to keep innovating
and after Avatar people said they saw
something they'd never seen before you
you managed to do it again and you've
shot several films back to back now so
how do you continue with the technology
to innovate knowing that some of these
films won't get released until a few
years from now you know we we kid
ourselves knowing that we're on in this
for the long haul that we're gonna know
how to com do Avatar 2 the day we finish
it and then that's going to be the
foundation for us to push for Avatar 3
and we won't know how to make Avatar 3
until we're done with Avatar 3 and we
always continue to push and we have
Partners like Joe La Terry who's the
senior visual affection profession at
Wet FX
no one wants to rest on The Laurels of
their past what is possible and in some
ways what I get excited about is I think
that what we do
unlocks the door for other filmmakers to
tell stories that could not otherwise be
told at a better level and what we want
to do is we want to show audiences
something that they go I can't get that
anywhere else I have to see it on the
big screen I have to be immersed in that
world and we want to continue to do that
with each of the sequels is it going to
take every filmmaker though 10 years
because it really is it's it's a million
pieces put together what is something
what is sort of like some technology I
know you've you have so much technology
and you sort of waited for the
technology to catch up to before making
the sequel that's why it took so long
but what is something that wasn't
available to the film in 2009 that
particularly gave you Joy to bring to
this one first of all what took the time
initially in our Gap was writing the
scripts it wasn't the technology it was
creating four scripts that would all
work as Standalone movies but together
create a larger epic Saga and that's
that took four years to get to that
point and then we started to design that
world I think you know the technology
that we focus on the most might be one
that surprises you it's the facial
performance it's being able to get
performances that transform these
characters where you just go they're
real they put them in makeup how did
they do that movies are about close-ups
movies are not about the worlds you
create around them the hardest technical
challenge for a company like web FX on
this is the water
is we all know what water looks like so
you can't just sit there and go oh make
it look good you have to make it look
photo real
and one of the best compliments I had
from somebody said okay John I know that
the navi characters aren't real but
where did you shoot those scenes of the
beautiful water we didn't
what effects did that and that's what's
amazing that's what's amazing but didn't
you use some extra some technology you
didn't have on the first one even for
the eyes we advance everything we
continue to do that so on the on the
first film we recorded people's
performances with a single standard
definition camera on these movies we're
using two high definition cameras we get
a much higher Fidelity of facial
performance WETA on their back end went
to a deep learning technology where we
put the cast into this sort of volume
where they went through all these facial
expressions and the systems learned that
and it learned how to interpret when
they got the data not based on the skin
but based on the muscles because what
what creates what we do with our faces
are the muscles inside we're not moving
our skin we're moving the muscles on the
inside and that's what WETA has now
solved wow Jim has said three films
that's what he has said I know you've
shot I think a quarter of four how have
you thought about
how by the time they come out the
release strategy how you people are
going to experience them are we going to
get more maybe virtual reality and like
we got Pandora with the last one are you
exploring that right now you know I
think what we're exploring is outside of
the theater how to expand the IP Pandora
the world of Avatar Walt Disney World
still become is their highest rated
attraction down there I'm proud to say
we're looking to do it in publishing
we're looking to do it in gaming where
we have a game that we're doing with
Ubisoft which is this it's going to be
this fabulous multi-player game not
retelling the story of our movie because
we do that we want these opportunities
to be the best in their field and play
in the in the sandbox that is Pandora
and and these characters and as we do
the movies you know our plan still is to
do you know a total of four sequels a
total of five movies in the theater in
the theater yeah and you know and and we
think that you know we have a
responsibility to help preserve this
experience that we all love called the
cinema and it's had a rough couple years
you know with the pandemic but you know
movies like Maverick movies like black
black panther you know movies even like
Spider-Man you know show that people
want it when you deliver them something
and if there was one movie I believe
that was ever made to be seen in a movie
theater it's Avatar the way of water
what about Elita battle Angel the fans
out there want to know from you are we
going to get more of that Universe you
know to the fans out there who want to
know about Elita battle Angel Robert and
I were just discussing that a couple
weeks ago so let's let's see where we go
with it